hello everyone and welcome to another
interesting game from the 22nd European
Team Championship it's a big old truck
versus Luka in Slovenian Grandmaster and
like I said we will cover a few of
Chalky's games during this championship
as we haven't covered any of his games
well in quite quite some time so this is
one of the games it's Ukraine versus
Slovenia and Charlie has the white
pieces he opens with E 4 with E 5 by
Lennox Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and
Bishop to b5 the rule opus defense is on
the board sorry the rule office is on
the board and now comes Knight to f6 the
Berlin defense we have castles and
Knight captures on e4 the the Rio gambit
is accepted here we have rook to e1
attacking the knight and Knight back to
d6 Knight captures on e5 recapturing the
pawn Bishop to e7 and now the most
popular move Bishop back to f1 tucking
it in for later Knight captures we're up
captures and castles this is the only
move anyone ever plays here now the
bishop can come to f6 which will make
room for the other pieces and you will
kick away the rook from such a nice
square with d4 by white and measure to
f6 look back the e1 and now rook to e8
trying to force white to move the rook
even more than white already did Bishop
to F for developing with ideas of
capturing here ruining the black's pawn
structure but root captures anyone Queen
captures anyone and now Knight to e8
there is the possibility of capturing
and d4 but then like we mentioned just
Bishop captures pawn captures and Knight
to c3 and you are up upon but you you
have neglected your development and you
have doubled the deep on and both of
these phones are just in the way of your
development so not something you want to
do it has been tried but in every game I
found in the database that black went
for this white one the game so here but
knife to eat instead this is the the
main move with nice the c3 and here
Bishop captures on d4 so grabbing a pawn
and Knight to d5
this is this has all been played before
the the pawn sacrifices is known so the
c7 point is under attack with d6
blocking the bishop and now Bishop to g5
attacking
Queen and now f6 this is one of those
positions where it's okay to play f6 and
Bishop back to III offering a trade of
Bishops and here Lenny grabs another
pawn bishop character son b2 and this
has all been played before we have
looked to be won by Chuckie and now
their disposition has been read before
c6 is a very important move that blacks
should play here but Lenny tried
something different
Bishop to a3 is also a possibility but
he played Bishop to e5 which is which is
quite interesting that's why I said it's
an interesting game because of course
you will see what white plays here it's
a it's not a mystery or anything if you
don't you can even feel free to pause
the video maybe maybe maybe just missed
it while I give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on trapping the
bishop on e5 and for those who that just
want to enjoy the show it's f4 so the
bishop is trapped the bishop has nowhere
to go
that's why this variation has never been
tried tried but I don't think this is a
blunder here black gives up the bishop
for two pawns and he has a massive
center which is what happened here in
the game we have c6 attacking the knight
kicking away from d5 Knights to b4 and
you still have don't have any good
squares for for a bishop and you don't
have any ways of creating some space for
your Bishop which tempo so you just have
to give it up a Bishop to a5 is played
and here chalky accepts the bishop on e5
with F captors on e5 and F captures on
e5 so here black is up two points chuck
is up a bishop and it's gonna be well
it's gonna be very interesting if white
is if black is able to start pushing
those central pawns will look the d1 by
chalky and now you do want to start
pushing d5 but if you if you do it too
early then your ePHI point comes under
attack
Queen g3 and once you defend it and then
comes Knight to d3 you attack it again
and it's well you can push a t4 but you
don't want to push it for you want to
push d4 here after efore it's just it's
just gonna be very hard for white to
play you have a lights for black to play
you have a light square Bishop all of
your pawns are on light squares and
you're already down a piece you don't
want to be yeah you don't want to have a
bishop for a pawn so
white would just be very very strong
here Bishop to d4 is coming and it will
be very hard for black to play this so
after Luke the d1 we have Queen to e7
first now the five point is nicely
guarded maybe d5 can be played and also
the rook can now enter the game but now
Chucky no longer allows it with c4
preventing d5 and now comes Knight to f6
I bring the knight into the game with h3
taking away the g4 squared from blacks
pieces and now Queen to east sex going
after the the c4 pawn shock he brings
the king a queen enter game while also
defending the c4 pawn Queen to h4 guards
c4 and worship the g6 g4 is a
possibility at some point so you don't
want your Bishop on f5 giving the the
pawn any tempos Tempe with Bishop to e2
now the bishop is very nice I need to it
controls this diagonal and also guards
the c4 pawn so if the Queen has to move
it's not a problem
Knights the e4 by black and here we have
looked the c1 the Queen no longer guards
the c4 point out that Ln just play
Knight to d4 Knight to a4 so rook the c1
chukka shifts the rook over to the C
file to defend his pawn and Queen to f6
now offering a queen trade and here
charty declines it heap goes back with
the Queen Queen to e1 and I'm Queen
again a 6 and here we have a 4 by
chalking a 6 black doesn't want to be a
7 point to remain a target you don't
really have a good way of developing
your rook as long as this point is an a7
so a six and A five
Chuckie grabs more space on the Queen
side and kinked h8 white still has a
light square bishop so you constantly
have to keep an eye on for ideas like c5
Bishop to c4 maybe maybe winning the
Queen okay d5 is a possibility now but
once you play King h8 you no longer have
to worry about such things
we've Knight the d3 by chalky and now
comes a rook to f8 finally developing
this rook bringing it into the game and
the Knights to f2 Chalky's of material
so as the general chess principle says
when you're up in material you should
trade down
Knight to g3 of course the black
declines this and Bishop to g4 now
grabbing more space with the bishop
pushing the Queen back Queen to e7
and now King 2h2 kicking the night back
with the King night the f5 and here
Sharky trade with Bishop captures Bishop
captures and now rook back to d1 the
rook is no longer needed the guard is c4
pawn so now you again prevent black from
pushing d5 the opponent will do a nice
job of preventing the the d5 thrust with
h6 by black and now back to c1 this
Bishop is now gonna go to this diagonal
it's gonna be a very powerful piece here
and also you clear the e-file for your
for your queen we've roped the f6 now
now guarding this d6 pawn because it's
not if this night to get to an
interesting square for example to e4
that the six pawn is gonna be under
attack and then you go you're gonna have
to give up your light square bishop and
then it's just it is just clear
advantage for white so here a Bishop to
b2 and now c5 it's an ugly move but if
you have to play it you have to play it
now you're stuck for the rest of the
game with the weak backwards d6 pawn but
you know if you don't have anything
better then you have to play a move like
that we look to d2 I useful move as
black has a light square bishop so you
don't want your rook on a light square
also it does a nice job of guarding the
the second-ranked as this Bishop might
find its way away over to c6 going after
the g2 pawn and if the rook sorry that's
not a move for example if the bishop
comes here the row comes to g6 you might
have some pressure against the g2 pawn
so the rook will do a nice job keeping
an eye on the g2 upon when the knight
moves Queen to f7 by black now again
attacking the c4 pawn and we have Quinta
e to again Sharky defends it King back
to g8 and now Bishop the c3 just
improving the position before making any
rash decisions we have worked to g6 and
now finally Knight to e4 so the d6 pawn
is under attack and if white black
doesn't want to give up light square
bishop you have to defend it so Queen to
e7 now okay both the rook and the Queen
are are guarding it and now Queen to f3
so how will how does white break through
here or can white break through here at
all
Bishop to d7 the bishop is now going
over to this diagonal which we already
mentioned and Queen to h5 you want to
unpin as soon as possible while also it
comes with an attack on the rook King to
h7 defending the rook and now rook the
f2 bringing the rookie into the attack
as well and now rush of the c6 assuming
this beautiful diagonal the night also
is under attack so night to g3 the rook
no longer is is eyeing the g2 pawn we
have Queen b6 now again going for the c4
pawn if black can get rid of the c4 pawn
then it will be black will be who will
have advantage if for example if this
one was here and d4 instead of on d6
then black would have a definite
compensation for the piece but here well
it's a backwards weak pawn on d6 not so
much Queen to h4 again Chuckie has to go
back he wants to guard the c4 pawn and
now Queen back to a e8 and here Sharky
decides for night to f1 of course I'll
move with the knight back the the knight
can now for example go to e3 from e3 you
can go either to d5 or to g4 or to f5
you want to make her Knight as active as
possible look back the e6 by lineage and
then now Knight the III we have Queen to
g6 and here comes Bishop to d2 so the
bishop here isn't doing all that much
black made sure of this so you have to
shift it over to some other diagonal for
example this one Bishop to b2 now it's
attacking the h6 pawn the Queen also is
attacking the h6 pawn and if the night
for example comes to g4 the knight will
also be attacking the h6 pawn maybe
something can be done about that
Queen to e4 by language now pressuring
the g2 pawn but like we said it's not a
problem the rook does a wonderful job
controlling everything on the second
rank Knight to g4 now with a triple
attack and the h6 pawn also you avoid
the Queen trade with Knight to g4 and
now Queen back to g6 bringing another
defender to the h6 pawn and here we'll
push up the e3 just the waiting move
seeing what what black will do the maybe
it does black have any plans or
something but it's very hard for black
to find the plan you don't have any
breakthroughs you don't you cannot pull
this you can put this
white will just capture create a passed
pawn you can never push this then all
your pawns become weak it's just a just
a very hard position to play for black
so here black played Bishop the e4 maybe
with ideas of Bishop to f5 or maybe even
Bishop to d3 to go after the c4 pawn
from behind but it doesn't work and I'm
sure you know why but if you don't feel
free to pause the video and figure it
out well I'll give you a couple of
seconds so for those we were able to do
it congratulations on such a nice move
with the bishop and for those who just
want to enjoy the show it's best shot
captures on h6 now of course when each
capture that if you don't capture it and
you're just you just lost another
opponent you're already done material
not something you want to do but just in
case we will show what happens for
example black is threatening some nasty
discoveries here so you can go back
Bishop to g5 now and well you don't used
to don't have a useful move for black
you can play something rook e8 and then
white can even give up a piece with
Knight to f6 check G captures rook
captures on f6 and you're just gonna
cobble up this pawn all of these points
will soon fall for example you can try
and trade Queens queen h7 but then rush
up to h6 you don't allow what you
control too much space
rook d8 you can try this guarding in the
d6 pawn but then just look the e6 you
open up an attack here and you can no
longer guard the DS exponent once this
point Falls then all of these points
will fall because if you move away from
the back rank you're getting made that
rook e8 check King of 7 Rock f8 checking
e6 and Queen to f6 will be made so this
is a one such I think that can happen if
you don't accept the bishop but lineage
captured it with G captures on age sex
and then track you just play rook to f6
and it was in this position that Luca
lineage resigned the game and yet
another victory for for vasili and took
in round two of the twenty second
European team championship he resigned
because well your queen is under attack
if you move the Queen your you lose the
dh6 pawn also your rook is under attack
so you have to capture the rook problem
is after you capture it Knight captures
with check and you lose the bishop as
well so after King
to g7 night just night captures Bishop
and the white is up a clean piece and
yes you could argue that you have two
points for the piece but you don't have
any counter play with those pawns you
cannot push the beep on you cannot push
the deep one and you don't have a good
move here so it's just why - who who
chooses what to play how to win and it's
it's just too easy a position for white
to play of course lineage knows this and
after rook to f6 he resigns in the game
so great a great victory for Chuckie in
round two and he also since already four
rounds have been played but he already
he drew against Momiji are in round
three and he drew against Lebanon in
round four I I thought about showing
those games but in the end I didn't but
just so you know Chucky is doing very
well in the European team championship I
don't know Ukraine won all of their
three matches I don't know how the match
against Armenia went but as it's still
being played while I'm recording this
but I will make another video from round
four and then we're gonna check out the
standings finally so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank mikaël Bogert and Robert Kiefer
for her condition to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check - in my previous
videos er think'll for watching and I
will see you soon continuing with the
coverage of the European Team
Championship checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and yes I'm still
preparing our next big saga so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest today